on this topic
is if you can touch up on masks and
sanitizers you know i have to put masks
on and
you know we have a very simple system
here at our office when employees work
we have about 100 employees that are
working here
and we have different color wristbands
green is you're comfortable for high
five handshake and fist bumps
you know yellow is you just want to do
one of these things you give me an elbow
and that's it and red is don't get close
to me keep six feet apart
so all our employees are very
comfortable but what are your thoughts
about the mask
and hand sanitizers so
let me say this
that's going to be the thumbnail just so
you know you know
look uh this is this is about
personal responsibility we recognize a
store
saying no shoes no shirt no no
service hey no mask uh
you know no hand washing no service um
look even if it has five
percent efficacy with this
infective a mischief maker let's
take the five percent but what i think
it really says
to anybody is look i
i realize how serious this is
and me wearing this maybe
isn't going to do much for me maybe it's
not going to do much for you but at
least
now you and i know that there is
something going on and we really ought
to pay attention for this so it to me
it's more
of a little sign saying this is the real
deal
and let's you know let's treat it like
the real deal
and i think there's enough there's a
cute little study
not not if you like my studies but so
they took a bunch of mice
and they put them in two cages and glass
all around except the partition between
the pages
were surgical mass and
the one set of mice were all infected
with covet
and the other set of mice were
uninfected and
they left it like that the mice on the
other side never caught covered
and i think there's enough anecdotes of
the in
in texas where the two hairdressers were
infected
yeah and uh they had what 120 clients
maybe 200 clients
none of those people got it i'll give
you a personal example
um at gundry md we film every friday and
we have a skeleton crew
we everybody is masked i
take my mask off when i'm in front of
the camera
uh people are you know clicking clap
clap boards and
near me and a few weeks ago it's been a
month now
uh one of these individuals and we test
all the time one of these individuals
tested positive
and uh nobody
tested you know caught it including me
and you know and he was around me but he
had a mask on
and so it's it's just so
dumb easy to do it's now
in my bias i've worn a mask all my life
so
it's no big deal for me but the
idea that mass are going to make you
retain
co2 or cut your oxygen levels i got news
here
there's so many studies of surgeons and
surgical personnel
it doesn't drop your oxygen level it
doesn't increase
co2 these are i don't know where this
stuff comes from
and but just for now just it just
says hey let's take this seriously i i
think i think the part i mean i saw your
video about masks where you said it
doesn't work
i saw the mask video you did saying it
actually doesn't work
uh but uh you know when you go out and
you're putting it on
i used to get uncomfortable when i would
get on flights and see
you know some of the folks that are
traveling from asia that had masks on
like listen that concerns me they're
paranoid you know we used to say they're
overly paranoid
right and now america's becoming the
overly paranoid and
uh i've looked at so many different
folks on what they've said even
even uh i think fauci said in one of the
videos he said it doesn't work it
doesn't have anything that's gonna do
it's not gonna prevent
the virus can still get through and i've
seen folks like yourself say the same
thing
but then i wonder why are people wearing
it if the experts are saying
it doesn't work what's the purpose of it
is it i understand social distancing
fully i fully understand i think yeah i
think the main thing
is it's just it's just a sign that
you know come on let's just keep that
distance
let's be aware yeah there they
mass do not filter viral particles
but i think one of the things that's
becoming clear and clear
is that this virus travels
on water droplets and
water droplets are caught by these mass
and i think maybe that's where
uh i was wrong and i'm happy to say it
and i'm i think fouchy early on he was
reading the literature about virus
transmission through mass and
that's what i was reading but he was
also worried
that our frontline workers um
we didn't have enough mass i mean
clearly we didn't have enough mass
and even if mass were minimally
effective it's all we have right yeah
and
i'm almost worried that well let's get
those guys to have it instead of us
okay interesting strategy interesting
strategy from his end
you